The alpha beta model is messy,
especially if you compare it to
the dynamic multi-threading model,
which you might use on a shared
memory multi course setting.
But, the basic argument for message
passing is that you need to get your
hands dirty if you want to be
efficient at large scales.
And that's the big idea of this lesson.
How to think about efficiency,
specifically in terms of
computation versus communication.
Now, the message passing model also
has at least one major weakness.
It forces you to think about
a lot of thinks like who and
how many processes there are, when and
how those processes communicate, as well
as how are the processes are connected.
So an interesting and
largely open research question is,
are there efficient algorithms
that are network oblivious?
That is, is there a framework for
writing and
analyzing algorithms that will be
efficient independent of the network.
I wonder.
[SOUND]